[Applause]
we just are such lucky people that we
get to eat this food and celebrate these
restaurants and what a better way to
kick off
our week uh celebrating meat then with
barbecue red oh please thank you so much
there are so
many amazing barbecue places around the
u.s
and we couldn't possibly feature them
all but we're going to try
to cover the three bases with three
different restaurants in three different
cities
all right everybody are you ready yeah
let's eat
all right let's go
welcome wild glove the smoke
really goes through like your nasal
passages it goes in your whole
old factories i don't think it'd be that
flavorful yeah
okay that's incredible all right adrian
you're a
james beard award-winning writer
food writer you've had your fair share
of ribs
from over 200 places i am so honored to
ask you what do you think of these
hey it's so good to be with you so yeah
i like this this is really delicate you
know tender
i put some of the grilling sauce that i
got on there so that added some flavor
and then
i love collard greens so i'm glad they
threw this in the mix this is a very
soulful touch
so stuff here have you tried these yet
the color greens okay get in this this
is
so good oh my gosh
what is going on in this it's perfect oh
my god
oh wow done oh thank you so
much adrian are you ready guys so ready
this is so different than the last one
ready oh
wow oh that'll wake you up
[Music]
okay you can certainly taste all the
spices in that dry rub even the texture
is different
right yeah and it really has like a nice
crust on it
emily it's your family tradition to have
a rib fest every year
what are your thoughts on these ribs
this spice it just completely
permeates the rib and the meat and it
just
tastes absolutely amazing it's not too
overwhelming
but it has just um just such a great
flavor to it i love it
have you guys gone to town on this slaw
yet i'm obsessed with this i haven't
stopped eating the ribs yet i know now
let me move over i feel so get ready
oh i know i know what's really great is
um
how crunchy the slaw is yeah
really good emily thank you so much for
your
um permeating especially words
favorites my honor please
okay everybody you ready let's eat
so different than the other two but
like that really beautiful kind of what
you really think is like a barbecue
sauce
there's certainly layers in this one yum
you're absolutely right ross mabel
you were born and raised in the south
and you consider yourself authority on
barbecue ribs will you please give us
your thoughts
well drew i have to tell you this rib is
good it's tangy it's um very
easy to get come off of the bone it's um
the meat is really tender and the sauce
the sauce is so amazing it's right on
point through it's really
really good i think you're absolutely
right about that sauce maybe
they're all very different
so different um okay well it's time to
vote this is gonna be really hard before
we do
we asked you all to vote on twitter
to say who your favorite rib joint was
from all these extraordinary places
and 61 of the vote was joe's
barbecue wow i can see why
so that's one vote for joe's kansas city
barbecue i love
that they're in like that shamrock gas
station that is so cool that makes you
feel like such a foodie
okay and now it's our turn all right one
at a time we're going to reveal
our favorite um so kick us off adrian
[Music]
wow joe's kansas city okay i really
really trust your palette okay beautiful
emily
what is your vote joe's was phenomenal i
agree but i have to go with kings
[Music]
okay stunning smart mabel what is your
vote
kansas
[Music]
oh my gosh that's three i know um
for joe's ross it's your turn okay
listen i
loved each one of these i don't have a
bone to pick with anyone but
one of them has to win and i have to say
it was the tenderness
and the side dish of collard greens that
put
king's restaurant over the road for me
it was so good
[Applause]
i have to do kings too
i was really not expecting how
much flavor would come out of those ribs
and i can't stop eating those collard
greens you're absolutely right
and i love the sauce so oh my gosh it's
a tie
so guess what both of those restaurants
are each getting the truck
yes
i love that and if you want to do your
own taste test
at home all of these restaurants can be
found on none other than
gold belly heaven on earth gold belly
that should be their motto
congrats to all three restaurants thank
you so much for honoring us by
participating in this
and i really want to thank our vff's
adrian
emily and mabel thank you so much for
hanging out with us today
you